as we mentioned monday is back to school
and the school district says it is ready
denise big day for thousands of families
and today 8 news now sitting down with
the superintendent to talk about some
concerns though as we move forward
christian casadas joining us now in
studio with more on that one-on-one
interview which also gave a glimpse into
what could be the superintendent's
legacy christian that's right guys well
just to be clear dr jesus jarrah is not
leaving the district but he tells us
when that time comes he wants to leave
behind a positive impact until then he
says there is much work ahead
as we move forward here with coveted
restrictions kind of rolling back
it seems that we have another threat on
the horizon which is monkey pox and
you know we already have two cases two
children in the u.s who who have monkey
pox um have there been any talks moving
forward i know that the risk level is
very low for for children but
it's it's still a concern it is and i'm
going to tell you our
our chief of health and safety our chief
health officer that works very close
with me
uh works very closely with the southern
nevada health district you know when
everybody comes back our educators came
back this week
up in our schools both we're going
through all the mitigation strategies
these are things that we're we're going
to continue to monitor there's been
talks about possibly breaking up the
school district your thoughts on that as
a superintendent you know when you
really think about it
that's going to take years to implement
i got to worry about the students
that i have in schools coming to school
on monday and the educators just to
provide the support and that's kind of
where i stand on this on your last day
when you look back on your time here at
ccsd how would you like to be remembered
how would you like to walk away that i
leave this place better than i found it
fully staffed
children are learning at high level
third grade reading scores to go up
graduation rates where my kids are
graduating and they're graduating going
into high
paying jobs
and those that want to go to college and
their opportunities are immense and
that's what i like to see
well again dr jarrah says there are many
challenges to overcome but his focus
right now is on the first day of school
and of course it's going to be a very
busy day and eight news now will be
there at the start of it come monday
morning christian costa is live local
now